Let's go to our old friend Dante from Florida
who I now I am convinced Dante, I'm going
to have it right today. You are a Bernie supporter,
but you like tools. See, but you were never
a tool C voter. You were always a Bernie voter.
Do I have it right now?
Yes.
Very good. What's up Don?
All right. So, um, I wanted to kind of push
back on the media explanation for what happened
in Iowa and that and, and a lot of people
in progressive independent media, the same
is too, that more likely than anything, it's
just record-breaking dropping in competence
that led to the whole debacle and Iowa. And
for me, that requires you to, to, to have
the assumption that the people at the DNC
in charge of the democratic party are operating
in good faith. And
Oh dear Dante, your connection just went lo-fi.
What, what you, we, we lost about half of
what you said there. You would. So I think
I know where you're getting at. What would
it take to convince you that this was in competence
and not a conspiracy? Like what, what would
you need to see?
There is nothing that, that, that couldn't
convince me that this is incompetence because
the DNC are not the people who running the
NC aren't. They're not good faith actors.
They have shown time and time again that they're
willing to do all types of unethical tricks
to undermine suppresses and primary to support
the establishment candidates. So just right
off the bat alone, they aren't the feedback.
So let me ask you this. Let's take it step
by step Dante, because you're, you're shot
out of a cannon today, which I can appreciate.
Let, let me ask you this. Let's imagine that
the Iowa caucuses were a completely fake,
fraudulent, uh, concocted thing by the DNC.
All they got out of it was one extra delegate
for Pete and never in the history of the democratic
primary has it come down to one delegate.
So was it worth it? Because in the end it's
not really gonna do anything for them.
The delegates aren't the, the main, uh, point
of Iowa, I think the amount of delegates that
we have in the democratic convention, so if
not winning, I will give you a huge lead in
delegates. It's the media narrative and the
momentum that you get. Iowa, you get the headlines,
you get to get the victory speech and the
deny Bernie Sanders that even though he won
the popular vote and they let P Buddha judge
run around and pretend like he just won this
fair and square, even though he had a, he
paid $41,000 at the company that created the
app.
Yeah, we know. We know about that. But let's,
let's deal more with the substantive part
that I'm interested in, which is, I agree
with you a lot of these early primaries, the
number of delegates is not the most important
thing. It's sort of the PR and being able
to claim viability and victory or whatever.
Um, I J I actually, I, I don't know yet whether
that's even really happening for Pete beyond
just doing well in New Hampshire. Like I said,
I still think we need a few more primaries
before we can even say that that's going on
because Amy Klobuchar is the one who most
drastically overperformed the polls in New
Hampshire. You've got in South Carolina, all
of a sudden Tom Stier comes in and he's pulling
second in a lot of super Tuesday States. Bloomberg
is doing better than Buddha judge. So I guess
I'm keeping an open mind. I want to see what
happens.
Yeah. I'm not saying that it just because
they did this, it's going to solidify, keep
budaj as the front runner. He's going to run
away with the Democrat nomination. But I think
it's important that we all recognize what
happened. This was a sham election where a
candidate had real influence. Possibly the,
the mechanism
you're breaking up again, Dante, but again,
I don't have, I don't have proof that Dante
had Dante. I don't have proof that Pete had
influence over that mechanism. We know the
connections. I just am unclear that the, the
degree, the degree of conspiracy that some
are asserting without proof seems completely
overwrought given the actual impact that it
had. But in any case, uh, we w it's certainly
fine for us to simply disagree. I do agree
generally speaking with you that the benefit
of Iowa for Pete was running around claiming
victory, not the extra delegate. We agree
there.
And then just one more point that I want to
make. So I think that there should be a lot
of, there should be conversation about what
we've learned in 2016 because even though
it was four years ago, it is incredibly relevant
and it's, we haven't really wrapped our minds
around the, most of the country has not wrapped
their minds around the fact that in their
own words, the DNC was caught breaking their
own charter, violating their own rules and
favoring one candidate over the other in the
primary and shooting Bernie Sanders.
I got to Dante. Listen, we've talked about
that so, so extensively. I don't want to dig
back into that. We've covered that for four
years, so I'm going to let you go. I've got
so many people that want to get on and I'll
always great to hear from you, but we covered
that
so much.